do you think you were too young to make
your first feature film
that's a great question um should every
22 year old make a feature film
probably not because you're definitely
going to be
learning a lot along the way and you're
gonna be inexperienced
um but i'm really damn glad that i did
because for me
it it kind of like set in motion
the idea that i could do feature films
and like filmmaking as a career
uh here in north carolina or you know
elsewhere eventually
louisiana um or anywhere else i find
myself in the future and
it kind of uh opened the door to that or
i think before then
there was a lot of hesitation and there
was some
um uncertainty on you know could this be
possible right
is this even a thing that people do um
and i don't know that there's like a
magical age where you make a film
uh any better than a different age or
whatever but i do think that it's just
experience plus time um so i like to
think that you know when i made my
second feature last year
uh it didn't feel as stressful to me
like
certainly there was still stress but it
felt probably like the most fun i've had
in filmmaking
where i think when you're making your
first one uh regardless of you know what
age you were
and i was certainly very young when i
did um
but i think that it was the
understanding that
you know hey the pressure's off a little
bit you know it's not the first one
you've already set the tone um and a lot
of times too i think like with the first
feature
you get really hung up on it as a
creative and as a filmmaker
because you say okay well this is going
to set the tone for everything i ever
make
and you know maybe it will maybe it
won't but there's a lot of famous
filmmakers
that i bet 99 of folks out there could
not name their first film because you
know their first film a lot of times
is uh you know kind of a scrappy project
and then the
the real first film is the one that got
the studio financing so
you know i'd say a lot of times uh i
wouldn't discourage
young folks from doing it i would just
make sure that uh
you know you're doing it for the right
reasons which is hopefully
to tell a story and to not get too lost
in the industry and really focus on the
the here and now of your film
or in some ways you could look at it
it's good to get it out of your system
like yeah
for some people going to europe if they
have that opportunity
they might not be able to do that later
on in life yeah
and why not do something huge like that
now yeah oh certainly because i'm
i know when i made son of clowns i was
and i was thinking very much the same
thing i was thinking
you know i've only made shorts and music
videos up to this point and you know
student films
um and i was really fresh out of film
school
and i was watching the the mark duplass
talk actually at
south by southwest in 2015 and he was
saying you know the cavalry isn't coming
he was saying you need to just do it and
you need to find out if you even like
this like
that's the the part that like stuck with
me
really like succinctly is you know
yeah i think i like filmmaking but maybe
you should make a feature to find out
for sure
and that luckily stuck and obviously you
know we're here so it worked out but
uh you know i think a lot of times it's
okay if filmmaking isn't for everyone
like
and i think there's a lot of people who
think you know the the kind of
glamorized version they've dreamt up in
their head for years and years is
is what filmmaking is but then when they
get down
and get their hands dirty then they're
like oh this is actually
entirely different you know let me see
if this is what i actually want to do
um and and to that i say no harm no foul
you know everyone should be able to
to try it out so uh yeah i think that's
that's a great
great point yeah i mean that's why i
think extra work is so great
yeah because i think it it whether it's
you know
a smaller set or whether you actually
get to sign up at central casting and
yeah
you see so much of what you like and
what you don't like and maybe some
people don't like to hurry up and wait
and be on set for for a 13-hour day or
whatever
but they might like another component of
it maybe they want to be at home editing
or
whatever so not everyone is important to
be on set like you said you know
yeah i remember one time doing extra
work and there was a guy that was a
director and he said this is
part of my film school i need to know
what this is like and
i remember he was great because i think
it was shaggy dog
the movie shaggy dog with tim allen and
it was like
it was action time for us and he just
started running around the set and i'm
like wow this guy's just making his own
rules and they loved it
so i was like okay cool this guy is
meant to be a director i guess
anyway that's a side note no that's how
he gets that like featured extra role
yeah
right jackie gets a sag voucher
you